alors je suis vraiment très heureux de
vous parler de désenchanter aujourd'hui
étant un énorme fan des simpson est
également de futurama enfin même si j'ai
un petit peu moins regardés 1
j'attendais cette création de matt
groening au tournant vraiment alors à la
bâche souhaitez vous parlez de
désenchanter dès la saison une
malheureusement la série venait tout
juste de se mettre en place et du coup
on avait trop peu d'informations pour je
puisse vraiment vous faire un trois
théories mais à l'heure actuelle avec
cette saison 2 les arcs narratifs
commence à se dévoiler et commence à y
avoir pas mal de choses à dire notamment
sur les deux prochaines saisons
car oui au final désenchanté aura quatre
saisons au total de 10 épisodes
alors voyons ça ensemble avec trois
petites théorie que j'ai à vous proposer
sur l'univers allez c'est parti
ah oui j'ai oublié y avoir du sport bien
évidemment de la saison 2 donc si vous
ne l'avez pas vu un ça ne sert à rien de
regarder la vidéo
[Musique]
alors bien que je sois content de vous
proposer des théories sur désenchanté et
bien tout reste approximatif encore
maintenant nous ne possédons que très
peu d'infos sur l'histoire de la série
et tous ses secrets
alors désolé et si par moments ce que je
dis peut sembler un peu tiré par les
cheveux contextualise on la théorie fut
go ou lis vos comme vous préférez est
l'un des 3 l à avoir quitté le pays des
elfes
néanmoins si ce dernier a fugué ce n'est
pas comme il faut fugue aux recherches
quelque chose quelque chose que celui
est le roi des elfes sont au courant et
sont à la recherche
le secret des secrets ce secret semble
se trouver à dreamland d'après la carte
de fugue au et à l'air d'être si
important que le peuple deux elfes
entier à migrer et ces derniers se sont
installés dans le royaume de drogue
alors qu'avant la saison une de
désenchantée
cela faisait apparemment des siècles que
des elfes n'était pas apparu nous sommes
donc sur quelque chose d'énorme pour les
elfes d'ailleurs fut go qualifie ce
secret comme la destinée des elfes
alors qu'est ce que cela pourrait bien
être et bien difficile d'affirmer quoi
sur la carte de fugue au et lors de sa
descente avec l faut dans les oubliettes
du château de dreamland
ce dernier semble rechercher quelque
chose en rapport avec un symbole en
forme de maison avec une boule brillante
sur le bout ce symbole est très présent
tout le long de la saison 2 et semble
être relié à la plupart des mystères
entourant la série pour le moment
seulement deux pistes sont pour moi a
souligné
la première est la présence dans fort
cachés dans les bas-fonds du château
dans l'épisode 7 l'étreinte gluante de
l'amour des règles des voix là il faut
un passage secret un couloir du
permettant d'aller sur une plage
secrètes sur les côtes du château quand
derek montre la porte à helfaut nous
avons la présence très claire du même
symbole que recherche fut go c'est lors
de la descente dans ce couloir que derek
et l faut tomberont par hasard sur des
amphores remplie d'un liquide peu comme
ces amphores sont marquées elles aussi
par le symbole présenté auparavant ce
qui souligne encore plus le rapport et
la liaison entre tous ces événements
artefact par le biais de ce symbole et
c'est là que cela devient très
intéressant derek va utiliser ce liquide
pour nourrir son ami poulpe alors oui
c'est un animal qui était destiné à
agrandir énormément cependant suite à
l'action de derek ce poulpe devient
carrément un kraken qui tue et dévaste
tout sur son passage
se pourrait-il que le liquide présent
dans les amphores aurait le pouvoir de
développer celui qui le bois et serait
ce que souhaitent les elfes qui ont
toujours été considérées comme
inférieures de par leur taille et leur
faculté et donc qu'il soit obligé de
vivre seule dans un monde un parent pour
ne pas se faire écraser par les autres
néanmoins ce symbole semble réellement
lié à tout ce qui entoure l'intriguent
de la suite de désenchantée et notamment
par rapport à dagmar effectivement been
reçoit un conseil de sa mère lui disons
de trouver la magie mais pas quelque
chose d'intérieur ou de spirituel been
doit trouver la magie autour d'elle
c'est alors qu'elle finira par trouver
des symboles de la roux vient les
symboles propres à la cité de dagmar qui
la conduiront symbole en forme de maison
alors est ce que les enfants ne seraient
pas la représentation de la magie entre
guillemets comme l'appelle dagmar
sachant que dans la direction artistique
le liquide versé par derek sang bleu
magique de par le sont enchanteurs mais
il reste un dernier cas de figure des
petits êtres bien cachés sont présents
dans cette saison 2 ils apparaissent
très brièvement jusqu'au dernier moment
de la saison où bing tombe dans un trou
ou très certainement formé par dagmar
lors de son exécution et se retrouvent
face à eux accompagnant la reine déchue
à son atterrissage bean se retrouve au
centre d'un socle avec le logo dont nous
parlions et semble vénéré par les petits
êtres si nous regardons le symbole d'un
peu plus près nous voyons qu'ils
ressentent beaucoup un design de ces
êtres avec une tête des yeux avec les
arcs de cercles et le chapeau avec une
petite boule au bout ces êtres ressemble
d'ailleurs énormément aux elfes et c'est
à se demander s'ils n'ont pas un lien
avec ces derniers il est possible que
fut go est le roi des elfes soit au
final à la recherche de ces êtres et qui
soit comme une sorte d'armé pour eux et
pouvant leur obéir qui sait ça se trouve
les amphores contiennent eux sont de ces
êtres bon ok je pars trop long dans tous
les cas que ce soit les amphores où ces
petits lutins il y a un rapport avec
l'avenir des elfes dagmar l intrigue
prochaine de désenchanter en général
[Musique]
bien il est temps de parler d'un
personnage qui je pense est très sous
côtés et que personne n'aurait
réellement soupçonné à la base aude
veulent vient de dévoiler beaucoup de
choses en cette saison 2 est énormément
de mystères sont à élucider
je peux vous dire qu'un deuxième
visionnage de la saison fut très
révélateur dans l'épisode 9 nous avons
la présence d'un homme de science qui
débarque dans une machine volante en
forme de dragon à dreamland deux
derniers se fera capturé puis sera
libéré par bin avant de nous dévoiler
l'incroyable ville de steam landes une
ville très futuriste et technologique
mais surtout très secrète
cette ville est quasiment inconnu de
tous et j'insiste sur le quasiment tous
effectivement cet homme de science que
bin accompagne avait une mission comme
affirmé par sa supérieure harriet ce
dernier et devait se rendre au château
livrer une arme et revenir sans se faire
repérer déjà gros mystère ici quelles
armes et livret a qui quand l'homme de
science réussi à joindre ses coéquipiers
suite à son échec
il précise qu'il réessayerons tout en se
méfiant de l'oreille attentive de binh
juste à proximité de lui
cette arme je vous le mets en mille et
je pense que vous l'avez tous compris
c'est bien le revolver que tout le monde
croit être un sifflet pour dragon ou une
baguette magique mais à qui devaient
être livrés larmes
et bien c'est hautevalle évidemment et
nombreux sont les détails qui le
souligne hautevalle est le plus proche
conseiller du roi
au point même qu'il est nommé en tant
que région du royaume
si quelque chose devait mal se passer
audeval a toujours su ce qu'était la
remet en question et à manipuler les
habitants du royaume quant à son utilité
déjà au moment de l'apparition du
revolver au moment où le roi manip est
l'objet hautevalle prend peur quand le
roi manipule larmes et souffle même de
soulagement quand il l'a repose c'est
déjà un indice très important ensuite
dans le dernier épisode de la série
quand hautevalle annonce qu'il va
pouvoir prendre le pouvoir en manipulant
terek ce dernier manipule le revolver
d'une main très sûr il sait quelle est
cette arme
il sait comment s'en servir et ça je
pense que tout le monde la déceler et
prouve vraiment des chaussures oswald le
fait qu'oswald sache manipuler larmes
prouve qu'ils
devait être celui à qui devait revenir
le revolver et ce qui veut dire caudeval
connaissent team landes et un rapport
avec tout ce complot néanmoins ce
dernier a eu de nombreux moments
portrait herzog sans se faire prendre et
ne l'a pas fait c'est assez difficile à
comprendre pourquoi
mais grâce à l'erreur de diaby ni
hautevalle a clairement profité de la
situation sans savoir ce qui allait se
passer
ce qui lui permet d'accéder au pouvoir
et d'effacer pin en parlant de bin tiens
hautevalle tient des propos étranges à
son égard effectivement quand gottwald
énonce been comme une menace
lors de son complot il est défini comme
une femme moderne frôlant le xiiie
siècle ce vocabulaire est clairement en
raccord avec le thème de la ville de
steam landes been étant réapparu au
château avec une des machines de steam
landes cela prouverait que cette
dernière était au courant de beaucoup de
choses et au moment d'expliquer les
faits hautevalle est le premier à
contredire la princesse pour
désapprouver sa parole
d'ailleurs la supérieure de l'homme de
science affirmé que dogues étaient donc
toujours sur le trône suite à l'échec de
son coéquipier ce qui veut dire que la
mission était de supprimer org pour que
quelqu'un d'autre et le pouvoir
et forcément le rapprochement avec autre
vol est évident ensuite cette même
supérieur affirme quand elle en
reconnaît been qui vont être dans un
sacré pétrin
quand le boss apprendra que la princesse
était ici annoncé que stimulante possède
un leader n'est pas surprenant mais
engrange pas mal de choses déjà cela
veut dire qu'il est probablement celui
qui est à l'origine de ce complot envers
dreamland et deuxièmement il est obligé
que nous le rencontrions dans les futurs
épisodes de la série
est il possible que ce boss soit
hautevalle et bien c'est possible
hautevalle connaissent team landes et à
créer un complot avec eux pour avoir le
pouvoir si haute vallée est un homme de
confiance pour ce team landes c'est que
soit il est le boss ou bien qu'il est un
lien de près ou de loin avec ce dernier
il se pourrait qu'un rapprochement est à
faire du côté de l'organisation secrète
tenue par oswald d'antrim landes
il est possible que cette secte soit
beaucoup plus profonde que l'on pourrait
le penser et notamment par rapport à
steam landes
enfin j'aimerais intervenir sur le fait
que dans la série haute vallée tête aux
côtés de dagmar avant qu'elle n'épouse
dog et habitat dreamland étant aussi
manipulateur et calculateur que la reine
il serait encore plus possible que le
complot de steam land est un lien avec
dagmar qui souhaitait elle aussi clock
tombe
tout semble réellement relié dans la
série que ce soit cette histoire de
symboles avec dagmar et le secret des
elfes ou bien ce fameux complot qui a le
même but que celui de l'ancienne reine à
la base mais le fait de caudeval
souhaite supprimer bean et dénonce
dagmar lors de l'audience prouve que
soit haute-vallée dagmar ne sont plus
alliés ou bien se pourrait-il qu'une
fois de plus un jeu de dupes soit
présent pour tromper le spectateur
[Musique]
cette histoire de prophétie est vraiment
très déconcertante et il est difficile
de savoir en quoi cela engage réellement
been de ce que nous savons
la famille royale marocaine du côté
maternel de diaby niçois celle de dagmar
possède une malédiction effectivement la
famille possède une dette envers les
enfers au point même qu'une porte y
conduisant est présente dans le palais
de lempire marot vient nous ne savons
pas vraiment ce qu'implique cette
prophétie médaille marc précise abine
que la famille de sa fille possède une
fortune familiale qui demandent
réparation une dette envers l'enfer dont
le retard est criant et que du coup ceci
permettrait à la famille de maintenir
son rang dagmar a donc mis au monde been
pour qu'elle accomplit cette prophétie
car elles en seraient les nous savons
que la cité de ma roue et donc dirigé
par la famille de dagmar et que son
commerce se basait sur la souris inutile
d'en savoir plus
d'un autre côté pour ceux qui s'en
souviennent il existait une cité très
florissante et très puissante du nom de
seaux d'eau mort et cette cité avait son
économie basée sur le serpent le serpent
en mangeant la souris on comprend très
vite pourquoi ce dôme horse est élevé
cependant la cité de ma roue a donc
décidé d'écraser celle de seaux d'eau
mort mais ne possédant aucune arme
ils ont dû avoir recours à la magie et
c'est là que les choses deviennent
intéressantes
effectivement maroua changé en pire la
cité de seaux d'eau mort et tous ses
habitants
leroy la cité voulant reconquérir son
peuple et sa gloire cherche à le
pendentif de l'éternité
mais malheureusement ce dernier ne
jamais trouver d'elfes et finit donc
changé en pierre toujours en possession
de la fiole la famille royale de mar où
posséder un rang mais fut très vite
dépassé par so do more voyant qu'il perd
des richesses etc loire la famille de
dagmar et de binh a certainement dû
faire un pacte avec les enfers pour
trouver un moyen de supprimer la ville
de sodome mort et cela expliquerait
pourquoi la famille est sujette à la
magie cette dette envers l'enfer serait
le paiement du présent café le diable
pour aider la famille royale a retrouvé
son rang et détruire la cité de so do
more néanmoins pactiser avec le diable
n'engendre rien de bon et cette gloire a
dû donc être de courte durée quand la
démence et la malédiction s'installa
dans la famille suit alors non paiement
vous voyez où je veux en venir
allez savoir comment bin dans les
prochaines saisons sera obligé de
pactiser avec ça
erquy la sauva du bûcher et nous
dévoilera qu'en fait elle n'est pas si
des monnaies qui on pourrait le penser
malgré ses actes passés néanmoins
j'aimerais souligner quelque chose nous
savons donc que dans le monde
désenchanté il existe trois royaumes
plus inquiets secret stimulante sans
derek been pourrait être l'héritière de
dreamland étant la fille de zob mais est
également destinée à être la future
princesse de ma roue ce qui fait déjà
deux royaumes à son actif enfin la cité
de 102 morts a subi le même sort que
dreamland récemment où les habitants
furent changés en pierre saubot mort est
toujours sauvable par le biais du monde
antique de l'éternité et du sang d'elf
cela irait à l'encontre des projets de
dagmar et de la famille royale mais il
est obligé que cela arrive à un moment
ce domaine pourraient être sauvées par
bin étant le dernier souhait le plus
cher du roi de so do more been pourrait
devenir la sauveuse et la souveraine de
ce peuple passé et là nous pourrions
trouver une raison à cette prophétie
been pourrait devenir la dirigeante
ultime du monde désenchanté
bien que pour elle elle ne soient pas
destinés à de telles vocation si cela
devait arriver la famille royale de mar
où on retrouverait son rang la fortune
royale serait réparé et la dette envers
l'enfer pourraient être payés
après je ne suis pas sûr que les enfers
recherche l'argent et c'est là le
mystère
nous ne savons pas ce que veulent en
faire en retour peut-être des âmes
je ne suis pas sûr la famille royale
auraient déjà été éteintes ces idées
sont très farfelues elles sont signées
argot rock mais écoutez cela pourrait
vraiment arriver à trouver sens longue
vie à binh
[Musique]
nous arrivons à la fin de cette vidéo
j'espère très sincèrement qu'elle vous
aura plu et comme vous avez pu le voir
j'ai changé de caméras [ __ ] j'ai enfin
une véritable caméra fini la vieille
webcam tout claquer la donc pouces bleus
s'il faut citer mes caméras qui font de
la bonne qualité
bref n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
partager la vidéo me suivre sur twitter
regarder des pubs sur youtube cet argot
rock et que le liner soit avec vous
allez ciao
[Musique]